New signs that the
US could
be moving closer
to giving Ukraine F-16 fighter jets.
President Zelensky
has been, of course,
pushing for this
and reiterated
at every turn, arguing
that they need the planes, the jets,
to defend against Russian missile
and drone attacks.
Natasha Bertrand
has more details on this
with this new development.
Natasha,
it seems that they're not
maybe not necessarily
opening the door yet,
but can we say at least
that they're still
not slamming a shot?
I think that's right, Kate.
And so what we've learned
is that two Ukrainian
pilots have been in the US
to train with the Americans
on flight simulator systems.
Essentially they are learning
how to fly certain American systems.
They're not actually operating
on those systems themselves.
On actual planes,
but they are kind of
getting instruction
from the Americans
about how to become better
pilots, for example,
not only on their own systems
but also to see how long
it would potentially
take them
to learn
a system like the F-16 burning,
for example,
or other kinds of American aircraft.
So this is described
by a senior U.S.
military official
as kind of a familiarization process
as something that is fairly routine
between the U.S. and Ukraine.
But it is actually the first time
that Ukrainian pilots
have come to the US
for this kind of training.
So that could be a kind of
a harbinger of things to come.
Now, at the same time,
the secretary of defense,
Lloyd Austin, is
in the Middle East today,
and he is commenting
on the situation in mood.
Of course,
very difficult as we just heard
Melissa Bell lay out there.
But he is saying that
even if the Ukrainians
don't succeed there,
that he does
not necessarily view
that as a strategic failure.
Take a listen to what he
told reporters earlier today.
I would
not view that as a
as an operational
or strategic setback.
I think it's more of a symbolic
value than it is strategic
and operational value.
What I do see on a daily basis is
the Russians continuing to pour
in a lot of ill trained
and ill equipped troops.
And those troops are very quickly
meaning their demise
So the question now, Kate, is
how long are the Ukrainians
going to hold out in dark mode?
Of course, we have reported here
that the U.S.
and some of its allies
have been urging the Ukrainians
to pull back
because, of course,
as you heard often say there,
the U.S.
does believe that this is largely
a symbolic
city of symbolic value
rather than strategic value,
getting them to pull out,
focus elsewhere
that may be
what the US
believes is for the best
for the Ukrainians
But of course, Zelinsky,
the president of Ukraine,
still viewing it as a key city
where they can wear down
the Russians, their kids.
All right.
Well, Natasha, thank you so much.
Joining me now
for more on
this is CNN military analyst,
retired Lieutenant General
Mark Hertling.
It's good to see you, General.
So this battle,
the battle in Boston,
the defense secretary Austin
and what Natasha just played for us.
Defense Secretary Austin
calling it a sum
having symbolic value,
more symbolic value
than strategic and operational value
if the Russians take it.
What do you see there?
I agree with Secretary Austin's
view, Kate.
It has been.
And by the way,
let's talk about mood
and how long
we have been discussing it.
Right.
It's been over seven months
since that city
has been under siege
by the Russians.
And on a weekly basis,
we have heard different Russians say
they're about to surround it
and the Ukrainians
continue to fight.
And every day I wake up to a text
from a friend of mine in Ukraine
that says the mood holds to words.
So they have been very successful.
It will never be a strategic
or an operational victory
for either side.
It will be a psychological victory.
And it already is for the Ukraine
Ukrainian forces
because they have held it so long
and have drained
so much
Russian manpower
in that cauldron of blood.
I wanted to ask you about that
toll on the Russians first.
I mean,
we have heard from more analysts
over and over again.
It's just the bloody toll
that this progress
has taken for the Russians
to get where they are in.
What price
have they had to pay to pull off
to pull this off if
if the Ukrainians do retreat?
Yeah, well, let's talk
numbers first, Kate.
And I'm not a big body count guy.
I learned early in my career
that's never a good indicator
of who's winning or who's losing.
But Alexi Dunlop,
who's the head of Ukraine's
National Security
and Defense Council, said last week
that Russia was losing
seven soldiers
for every one Ukrainian soldier
killed them.
The defense of that city.
That is just unbelievable
from a military
perspective, perspective.
And I think
your reporters,
both Natasha and others,
have talked about this
general search guy
who's commander of Ukraine's
ground forces visited
last Friday
and talked about the state
of the city's defense
with the military commanders
and said let's continue to hold
because we can't.
Today, there were reports
of Ukrainian
special operations commanders
visiting the city and saying, here's
what we need
to do to continue to push the fight
and kill even more Russians.
So it is something that's trapped
Russia in this in this area
that they can't use other places.
We've been talking
also about the potential
for offensives in counteroffensive.
I believe Russia
has been on the offensive
for quite some time now
and they are losing
considerable amounts of their forces
in doing that.
And soon we will see Ukraine
one more
and more Western
type of equipment
gets into their hands.
They will start their counterattacks
and their counter offensives.
But the entire time Ukraine
has been holding
the Russian force in this area
and preparing to attack
in other places. Yes.
So interesting this morning.
Also, Russia says that its air
defenses
brought down three missiles
over Belgorod in Russia.
And The New York Times
general is reporting
that Ukrainian
special forces
made a rare public acknowledgment
actually today that they conducted
a cross-border strike in Russia.
Destroying an unmanned observation
tower is how they describe it in the
region using a drone strike
that caught my
attention because
I wanted to ask you
what you see
really in
any Ukrainian strikes happening
within within Russia
and also Ukraine saying as such.
Well, those
who have not served
in the military, Kate,
I kind of think this is
like a video game
that you just find a target,
shoot at it, send drones there
But what is happening
really is intel collection
to conduct further strikes.
And when you're seeing
the Ukrainian forces launch drones
into Russian Oblast,
like Belgorod, like version
like even outside of Moscow
and Saint Petersburg,
that knock down some of their
their air
defenses
Russia is now having to take
air defenses
and surround those cities,
taking them away from the frontline.
So it's a matter of material
that's moving back and forth
inside of Russia
to the front line of Donbas
and back again.
So if Ukraine can continue
to threaten inside of Russia
that require
the Russian generals
to move their equipment back
to defend their forces.
So it is all really
the continuation of this attempts
at attrition, warfare,
knocking out as many forces
as you can
and at the same time
destabilizing the defense
that Russia
has been attempting to build on the
on the front lines.
They can't have it both ways.
So, you know,
when you're threatening cities
that are 100 miles
away from the front line,
the Russians have to
do something about it
that they don't want to do,
protect their citizens, just like
Ukraine has
been protecting their own.
General Hertling, it's
great to see you as always.
Thank you.
Let's speak now to CNN military
analyst Colonel
Cedric Clayton Layton.
Good morning, sir.
Thanks for joining us.
Good morning, Jim.
Good to be with you.
This has been a bloody fight
for weeks,
so a lot of tremendous
number of losses
on the Russian side,
but also the Ukrainian side
that there's worry
that this is less about dark
mode itself
than Ukrainian forces
showing they'll fight
for every inch of territory.
They don't want to give any ground
anywhere.
And I wonder,
is this the right use
in your view, of Ukrainian resources
and manpower
No, I certainly understand
the desire
to keep every inch
of Ukrainian territory.
And it's very much
an emotional argument.
And kind of like the Alamo in Texas
you know, back in the 19th century.
But, you know,
there's a reality here
in the Ukraine
need to save as many of it's
soldiers as possible.
This is not the right strategy
for the situation
that they find themselves in.
There are times
we have to do a tactical withdrawal.
So other times
we have to do
a strategic withdrawal.
And this is one of those times
where it becomes imperative
to save
as many Ukrainian soldiers
as possible
to basically fight another day.
And what that means is
they have to really pull back
to more defensive
positions, ones that they can hold
so that they can save
as many of their
own people possible.
What does this mean
for the next step?
Russia has been attempting
some sort of offensive,
at least throwing more more men,
more manpower, in the these
without making much progress.
Ukrainians planning
a counter offensive.
Does ceding back much at all imperil
Ukraine plans to counterattack
and try to gain back
more pieces of Russian
held territory in the east?
Not I think that's
one of the biggest worries
that the Ukrainian command has,
and it's a legitimate concern.
But if you perform a
strategic withdrawal
in the right way,
you can actually save
not only your troops,
but also your capability.
And this is
what's important
is to save as much capability
as possible.
In order to mount a counteroffensive
And then, for example, mount
the counteroffensive,
let's say,
in the south, around Boulder
or some other area
that they believe is softer.
That's the kind of thing
that I think
they should
be considering at this point.